[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now earlier in
the show we updated you on the britney
spears conservatorship now let's break
down what a conservatorship actually is
with eric palacios and associates the
sponsors of this next segment eric
welcome back
good to be here
all right we are talking about the
latest in the brittany spears case um
her conservatorship as of today you know
conservatorship is still in effect but
no longer controlled by her father jamie
spears so let's just start off by
defining what a conservatorship is for
anyone who's been following this news
and kind of lost
sure conservatorship is when a judge
appoints someone other than yourself
that can be a guardian
an attorney a cpa a family member
anyone to manage all your financial
affairs
okay and what more power does the
conservator have what else can they
control
they basically become like your parent
when you're a miner they control
health decisions financial decisions
what to buy what to sell
how you handle your day-to-day
activities so it can be very very
detailed and all-encompassing
wow and and how are conservators
compensated for this for this position
that's an interesting question uh they
get paid generally uh from the estate
that they're managing so in this case uh
if someone has millions and millions of
dollars then that allows the conservator
to charge uh for their time for their
travel expenses uh and they can pretty
much expense uh
most of their activities as long as it
has something to do with the work
they're doing as a conservative
that's something a lot of people might
not know and how does the
conservatorship end i'm sure there's a
couple different ways that that can
happen it depends state to state but
normally there is a time limit uh
california for instance most
conservative ships have a one-year
limitation and then they have to reapply
to continue that's what's interesting in
britney spears case is that it lasted
for so long 13 years and it's still
ongoing we think it's winding down but
it's really a long time
okay and do you have any predictions on
how this will end for brittany
well uh in my opinion it should have
ended long ago uh a conservatorship uh
is done when the person cannot take care
of themselves we've seen brittany
perform we've seen britney out and about
uh during these last 13 years so even
though she might have at some time
not been well enough to handle her
affairs
in the public's
viewpoint she is and has been for some
time she doesn't have to do a better job
than her conservator or her father she
can blow her money if she wants to but
if she has the mental ability to handle
her own affairs she should be allowed to
do that right that's her prerogative
well we will definitely keep everyone
posted on this on the latest news of the
britney spears conservatorship case
thank you so much for those for that
insight
definitely an interesting case and we'll
stay on top of it absolutely okay eric
see you later
thank you eric palacios and associates
for sponsoring this segment for more
information give them a call at
702-444-7777